c'est le conflit le plus meurtrier de
l'histoire la seconde guerre mondiale a
fait plus de 50 millions de morts
dimanche 8 mai la france a commémoré le
71e anniversaire de la fin de cette
guerre en 1945
un rendez vous incontournable pour magny
les hameaux et pour ces élèves qui ont
réalisé comme chaque année un livre
infinie
à cette occasion ils écrivent les noms
des morts pour la france magny cours
dans un livre qui est reproduit chaque
année et c'est la raison pour laquelle
donc il est infinie l'objectif est
vraiment de que la mémoire passe de
génération de génération originalité de
ce douzième tome du livre infinie les
élèves de 5e du collège albert einstein
ont également créé un champ leurs canons
à l'unisson a été chanté accompagnés
d'un orchestre lors de la cérémonie
devant les élus et les habitants
non
on est parti de la symphonie numéro un
malheur le du troisième mouvement
je suis fier de ses élèves qui ont
vraiment donné beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie pour réaliser ils ont créé les
paroles en partenariat avec le
professeur de français professeur
d'histoire-géo les anciens combattants
sont intervenus en classe dans la
chanson et à on commémore les morts en
fait on sait grave en fait que ce qui
s'est passé donc il faut que tout le
monde s'en souvienne pour moi ce livre a
servi de d'apprendre parce que c'était
la guerre en précision parce que je
savais ce que c'était mais plus ou moins
c'est une responsabilité
je compte en un hommage visuel et
musical mis à la disposition du public à
la maison des bonheurs de la ville pour
ce premier canon à l'unisson le maire a
même proposé aux élèves de revenir le
chantait à chaque commémoration du 8 mai